ANNOUNCING A 2020 RALLY IN
NORTH CAROLINA.
THE SAME DAY AS MUELLER'S
TESTIMONY.
JOINING ME NOW IS KEN STARR,
ALONG WITH FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY
BRET HOLMAN, AND DAVID SEAN.
GREAT TO HAVE ALL OF YOU WITH US
HERE.
JUDGE, LET ME START WITH YOU.
I REMEMBER THE COMEY TESTIMONY
VIVIDLY BECAUSE I RIGHT ABOUT IT
EXTENSIVELY IN MY BOOK.
AND IT STRIKES ME THAT IF THERE
IS AN EMAIL THAT ESSENTIALLY,
YOU KNOW, LORETTA LYNCH, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND SAYING, I'M
NOT GOING TO LET THE CASE GO TOO
FAR AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON, MY
GOODNESS, DOESN'T THAT NEED TO
BE DECLASSIFIED?
>> YES INDEED, GREGG, I THINK
YOU WHEN, AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE IN AGREEMENT, WE NEED
MORE RATHER THAN LESS.
AND ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
VERY SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF THE FBI'S
LEADERSHIP EVEN TOUCHING ON THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
DURING THAT PERIOD IN 2016
BEFORE THE PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
WE NEED DECLASSIFICATION.
HAPPILY, AS YOU KNOW,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DELEGATED
THAT RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES BILL BARR, WHO IS
VERY EXPERIENCED PIT HE WILL DO
A VERY PROFESSIONAL JOB OF
PROTECTING NATIONAL SECURITY,
SOURCES AND METHODS, BUT ALSO
THEN GETTING THE INFORMATION NOW
THAT WE THE PEOPLE NEED IN ORDER
TO MAKE OUR OWN JUDGMENT ABOUT
WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> Gregg: DAVID, THE EVIDENCE
IS PRETTY COMPELLING THAT THE
FIX WAS IN.
THAT HILLARY CLINTON WAS NOT
GOING TO BE CHARGED.
I WILL POINT YOUR ATTENTION TO
WHAT PETER STRZOK SAID IN
PRIVATE TESTIMONY.
HE SAID THAT IT WAS THE DOJ
ATTORNEYS THAT TOLD THE FBI TO
CHARGE, TO CHANGE GROSS
NEGLIGENCE TO EXTREMELY
CARELESS, AND THEN HIS LOVER,
LISA PAGE TESTIFIED THAT THE DOJ
SAID "YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
CHARGE GROSS NEGLIGENCE."
WAS THE FIX IN?
>> ABSOLUTELY, VERY, VERY
TROUBLING.
AND REMEMBER, REMEMBER MICHAEL
HORWITZ INSPECTOR GENERAL SAID
THAT HE DID NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
ALL OF THE EMAILS.
IF SO WE STILL HAVE NOT SEEN
SOME OF THE EMAILS BETWEEN
STRZOK AND PAGE.
YOU DISCUSSED THIS BRILLIANTLY
IN YOUR BOOK STARTING AT PAGE 40
ABOUT THE WHOLE FIX THAT CLEARLY
WAS IN.
AND JUDGE SPOKE BEAUTIFULLY
EARLIER.
HE IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
BUT THERE IS A QUESTION AS TO
WHETHER AND WHY THE INFORMATION
WAS CLASSIFIED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
I FRANKLY DON'T BELIEVE FORMER
DIRECTOR COMEY THAT THERE WAS A
NEED FOR IT TO BE CLASSIFIED.
>> Gregg: I WONDER IF YOU
BELIEVE COMEY, BECAUSE HE SAID I
HAVE NOT COORDINATED OR REVIEWED
THE STATEMENT IN ANY WAY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OR ANY
PART OF THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT I AM ABOUT
TO SAY.
THEN HOW COME FOUR DAYS EARLIER
PAGES SENT A TEXT THAT SAID SHE,
LYNCH KNOWS NO CHARGES WILL BE
BROUGHT TO?
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE MORE
SHOCKING DISCOVERIES I THINK FOR
MANY OF US THAT WORKED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
JIM COMEY HELD HIMSELF OUT OF
HAVING THE WHITE HAT.
HE WAS ALL ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
ALL ABOUT THE RULES, FOLLOWING
THE RULES.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE SAID IN THE
HEARING AND HE SAYS, I WOULD
HAVE TO GIVE A CLASSIFIED ANSWER
IN RESPONSE TO THAT.
WELL, HE STUCK WITH THAT AND HE
CONTINUES TO USE THAT AS THE
DEFENSE MECHANISM TO REVEAL THE
THINGS THAT HE WAS DOING.
MANY OF US THAT WERE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, WORKED
WITH JIM COMEY WOULD HAVE FIRED
JIM COMEY INSTANTLY ON MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE NOW KNOW HE
WAS INVOLVED IN AND HOW HE
HANDLED THEM.
>> Gregg: AND JUDGE STARR, THE
TWIST ON ALL OF THIS IS THAT IT
WAS THE RUSSIANS THAT
INTERCEPTED THE EMAIL, WHICH
ONLY UNDERSCORES THAT
HILLARY CLINTON REALLY DID
JEOPARDIZE NATIONAL SECURITY
WITH HER PRIVATE UNAUTHORIZED
UNSECURED SERVER EVEN THOUGH
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID OH, GEE,
SHE DID NOT JEOPARDIZE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> YES, AND THAT CANNOT BE
RIGHT.
IT ABSOLUTELY WAS SO
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WOULD DO WHAT
SHE DID AND DO IT INTENTIONALLY.
AND THE CHANGING OF THE
CHARACTERIZATION I THINK IS,
WELL, TO ME IT IS UNPARDONABLE.
YOU DO NOT WHEN THE FBI COMES
FORWARD WITH A CONCLUSION BASED
ON THEIR VERY CAREFUL EVALUATION
OF THE FACTS THEN SAY, NO, WE
ARE GOING TO CHANGE THAT.
THAT IS NOT YOUR VIEW.
YOUR VIEW IS INSTEAD A SOFTER
AND GENTLER VIEW.
SO THERE IS JUST AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROFESSIONALISM, FRANKLY OF THE
DOJ AND ITS RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE FBI.
LEADERSHIP IN PARTICULAR DURING
THE COURSE OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THE LORETTA LYNCH EMAIL.
IF THIS IS TRUE, IT IS
ABSOLUTELY EXPLOSIVE, BECAUSE
THAT SHOWS THAT THERE IS A VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE OF INTEGRITY AT
THE VERY TOP OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Gregg: IF PEOPLE LIKE
LORETTA LYNCH AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE MADE A DECISION ON
NOT TO CHARGE FOR POLITICAL
REASONS, IS THAT OBSTRUCTION?
>> ABSOLUTELY, IT IS OBSTRUCTION
AND SEVERAL OTHER THINGS.
IT IS SO PROBLEMATIC.
LISTEN, AS I HAVE TOLD YOU
BEFORE, MY FATHER WAS AN FBI
AGENT AND WE ARE VERY PROUD OF
THAT.
WHAT THESE PEOPLE DID, COMEY,
McCABE, STRZOK, PAIGE, TORE
DOWN THE REPUTATION OF ONE OF
THE GREATEST AGENCIES IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND CIVIL LIBERTARIANS LIKE A
JERRY NADLER SHOULD BE OUTRAGED
BY IT.
THEY SHOULD BE SHOULD BE
OUTRAGED BY THE PEOPLE THEY HAVE
EMBRACED.
THAT TELLS YOU THAT THERE TRUMP
HATRED OUTWEIGHS EVERYTHING ELSE
IN THEIR AGENDA.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY WERE
ELECTED TO DO.
>> Gregg: I WILL LET YOU HAVE
THE LAST WORD.
>> WE SHOULD BE AFRAID OF WHAT
PATTERN WE ARE STARTING TO SEE.
WE HAVE SEEN THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI FOLLOW A PATTERN OF HIDING
THINGS THAT HE DOES NOT WANT US
TO SEE, LEAKING THINGS THAT HE
HOPES TO GET OUT THERE, NOT
CHARGING HILLARY CLINTON WHEN
MANY OF US THOUGHT THAT THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CHARGES.
AND WHY?
WHY DOES HE COME OUT RIGHT
BEFORE THE ELECTION?
BECAUSE HE THOUGHT HE WAS GOING
TO WIN.
AND HE WAS GOING TO COVER HER
AFTER SHE BECAME PRESIDENT.
IN THE SAME PATTERN OCCURS WITH
THE FISA COURT WHEN WE HAVE THE
STEELE DOSSIER AND THOUGH ALMOST
ACTIONABLE REQUEST FROM THE FBI
TO THE FISA COURT THAT WE NOW
KNOW IS NOT ACCURATE.
SO WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS A
PATTERN THAT SHOULD SCARE FOLKS.
THAT'S WHAT CONGRESS SHOULD BE
LOOKING INTO.
IS WHAT IS IT TO THOSE IN POWER
ARE DOING WITH THE POWER THEY
HAVE?